Renault's talisman brought new elegance
to the midrange in 2016
its conspicuous new design as an
eye-catcher on the street the chic
French cars available as a sedan or
station wagon
once I didn't Carlson car testa enos
Petrie says station wagons are a long
familiar body form but that doesn't mean
they're boring
today she's testing The Talisman grand
tour which has not only some new visual
features but a real technical surprise
too The Talisman offers a choice of two
turbocharged gasoline and three turbo
diesel engines eNOS is testing the car
were the most powerful diesel which puts
out 118 kilowatts it accelerates from
zero to one hundred and nine point six
seconds top speed 213 kilometers an hour
the engine will as two differently sized
turbochargers already reaches its
maximum torque of 380 Newton metres at
1750 revs The Talisman has a six speed
double clutch transmission the nearly
4.9 meter long station wagon is
extremely maneuverable the technical
highlight is the dynamic all-wheel
steering says eNOS when you take a curve
at speeds of up to 80 kilometres an hour
at the rear wheels turn in the opposite
direction providing more dynamics and
agility you really see the difference
for control is the name of the system
that turns the rear wheels to up to 3.5
degrees this shrinks the cars turning
radius by 80 centimeters to 11.30 meters
the rear wheels tire tread protrudes
clearly from the wheel well
to compare here you see the moment when
the car begins moving straight ahead
again
[Music]
flowing parallel lines characterized the
talismans exterior design the daytime
running lights extend far beyond the
headlights to the bumpers a long hood
highly convex surfaces on the doors and
chrome trim on the side windows make the
car seem even longer
[Music]
the 19-inch alloy wheel rims are like
designer accessories at the rear the
expansive light design underscores the
cars with
[Music]
yeah I'm HEC Medina says the taillights
are a true high point Renault played
with light and here it almost grows
together in the middle at the moment the
only other cars with that are sporty
models like the Audi TT and the Porsche
911 on the rear hatch opens at the push
of a button offering a roomy trunk but
the broad lacquered and unprotected area
on the bumper is impractical when you
stow cargo
[Music]
snazzy details and modern design are the
strengths inside
often on the penis likes the talismans
interior to the large vertically
arranged display replaces a great number
of buttons among the buttons
this one here catches your eye it has a
flower with five petals each standing
for a different driving mode when Hina's
presses here the lighting mood changes
along with the driving mode one of the
modes can be defined by the owner the
multi sent system with its adaptive
suspension adjustments and other
adjustment options his standard
equipment even in the basic model
compared with other cars that have
ambience lighting the colors here are
very intense but they can be dimmed down
[Music]
the playful colored light contrasts with
the clear arrangement of the interior
the materials used seem very high
quality and are pleasant to the touch
[Music]
the raglan penis was very pleased with
the design of the talisman grand tour
but especially with its maneuverability
which really surprised her she wouldn't
have expected it from a vehicle for
point eight six meters long
unfortunately the dynamic all-wheel
system for control is not standard
equipment but comes in a one thousand
seven hundred euro package but in
combination with the rear-view camera
it's worth the price because it makes
the car much easier to handle in
everyday driving
[Music]
you